tras casi 11 horas de deliberación
lobbys y bajo prefecto urban des en el
momento del genocidio tutsi fue
condenado a 20 años de prisión el ex
alto funcionario de 78 años fue absuelto
como autor pero declarado culpable como
cómplice la fiscalía había pedido
perpetua por responsabilidad en cuatro
matanzas que ocurrieron en su prefectura
de gijón goro en el sur del país una de
las zonas que más ha sufrido el
genocidio huyen
el estilo de excepción para nosotros hay
una relativa de excepción porque por
ninguno de los hechos por los que fue
procesado se le condenó como autor de
genocidio génesis como usted oye no
sólo fue condenado por complicidad
más entonces mis pensamientos van a
todas las víctimas de la iglesia de
khyber o por las que no se le consideró
responsable el juicio que comenzó el 9
de mayo y que se llevó a cabo en francia
es el primero para un alto funcionario
que tuvo un papel en las masacres
durante los 41 días de audiencias en las
que intervinieron 115 testigos peritos y
partes civiles quedó claro que el ojo
gris y bauta no dio órdenes ni llamó al
hoyo pero como autoridad nunca hizo nada
para impedir lo ocurrido su prefectura
donde el 75% de los residentes tutsis
fueron exterminados se recibió incluso
las felicitaciones del primer ministro
de la época por su colaboración durante
los asesinatos masivos
escoltado por policías tras el anuncio
del veredicto
la misiva justa fue encarcelado el ex
prefecto tiene diez días para apelar su
sentencia
según las naciones unidas al menos
800.000 tutsis murieron durante el
genocidio en ruanda entre abril y julio
de 1994